any time there was a proposition
to yes impose the values of liberal
societies
on the incoming minorities this is
probably the most shocking bit
of the entire interview she talks
candidly
and audaciously about imposing
western values on immigrant populations
that is one side of the story but
there's also another side of the story
there's two sides of the story when you
when jordan peterson talks about slavery
and segregation racism in the west
but she doesn't offer the same
charitable interpretations of two sides
of the story when she's talking about
the muslim world
is the hijab 10 discount code for 10
discount on a wide range of products
including premium ethiopian black seed
products
how are you guys doing this is a video
of review a review of an interview that
recently took place between iron hersey
ali and jordan peterson
now before i indulge in the foxy norse
in the hilly pulification
of the counter factual and inoperative
quantifications
of iron hersey ali i would like to
stress one point
that both individuals are not
specialists in islam or muslims they are
really not
academically qualified or trained to
deal with these matters
and it would have been clever had both
of those individuals taking a page out
of
wittgenstein's book tractus
where he mentions whereof
whereof one cannot speak thereof
one must remain silent but despite the
fact that jordan peterson
consistently mentions his own ignorance
on the topic of islam and muslims
he continuously and persistently
calls people who are ultra crepitarian
and who have no formal qualifications of
islam
except for a claim that they once
belonged to the body of muslims
to speak on his podcasts as if they have
some kind of
academic insight to offer what we will
realize with this review instead
is that there is no academic insight to
offer
let's start with exactly the method
that we're talking about in this case is
the social scientific method
but before we do so let's recognize the
argument that's been
made here by iron hersey alley that
there is a correlation
a strong positive correlation between
immigration
and sexual violence to women in
particular
this among many other problems that
you'll find with immigration
and what kind of immigration it's muslim
immigration in particular so
the first thing that needs to be
questioned is is iron hersey ali
going to provide us with scientific or
statistical data such that we may
look at it with an academic eye or is
she
going to be anecdotal from beginning to
end
unfortunately what we find with this
interview
is that there is absolutely no semblance
no semblance of academic rigour and in
fact the entirety of the interview
is a reference to anecdotal information
with the limitation of one case study
hercy herself talking about her own
story
which peterson thinks she's so heroic
for having gone through these
experiences
but jordan peterson asks hersey a
question
he asks he actually says i'm triggered
as a social scientist
because there's many issues i mean you
do say right off the bat
uh this is a trigger warning for the
entire book
reading it you should be triggered well
i would say i was triggered by reading
it i was triggered partly
as a social scientist i would say to
begin with and he mentions
of the issues in question is the fact
that how do you define
sexual violence against women let's take
a look at what he says
how do you define sexual assault for
example
now you could define it as the
if you define it by the most severe
crimes let's say
rape then you miss
all the data that might be obtained when
you
consider all the other forms of sexual
misbehavior
now this problem is real because in
second wave feminist
kind of academic literature you'll find
extremes
you'll find extremes like for example
mckinnon catherine mckinnon
who says that sexual intercourse
is a form of rape actually
even if if the person consents this is
in western academic literature
i know um jordan peterson has had
warrell farin on his uh podcast in the
in the past
and he's been critical of these
approaches and world farron himself
mentions in the myth of male power
these ridiculous notions of definitions
relating to sexual violence
hersey ali doesn't recognize the issue
here with definitions
and she doesn't realize because there is
no uniform generalizable
robust definition that everybody agrees
with in relation to this
violence against women such that
comparisons can be made cross-culturally
or even within the same
location so she starts talking once
again about
anecdotes but jordan peterson comes back
again and asks her some more
interrogatory questions
what's really interesting is that at
minute 12
second 38 iron hersey
candidly admits that she has she does
not start with statistics let's see what
she has to say
and so i don't start fast with
statistics so i i you know i really want
i'm not a social scientist
and now that's ridiculous
not the fact that she's not a social
scientist but the fact that you're
conducting a study
which is a social science
study and you're admitting that you have
no qualification no expertise
no training no ability
to act as a social scientist now this is
analogous to someone going to a doctor
asking for a prescription and then the
doctor turned around says
you know i'm i don't start with
prescriptions because i'm not a doctor
it would not be acceptable in any other
field
so why is it possible that she can be
treated as an academic and a social
scientist
when in fact she admits to the fact that
she is an ultra crack badarian
why is it possible that she can continue
this and that there is not a
push from peterson as we've seen with
him and kathy newham for example on
channel 4
a debate well known debate the same push
that he has with other second wave
feminists where he
completely dismantles their duelist
narratives we don't find here
there's an acquiescence here and i think
the reason is this
if iron hersey ali was kathy newman he
would have eaten her for breakfast in
that interview
but you're exercising your freedom of
speech to certainly risk offending me
and that's fine i think more power to
you as far as i'm concerned
except you haven't sat there and
i'm sorry i'm just trying to work that
out i mean
gotcha you have got me but he acquiesces
to her
lack of rigor and sophistication
academic sophistication
because she exists with him in the same
anti-muslim
echo chamber and that's the reality and
he knows it
when was the last time that jordan
peterson has ever
in his entirety of his career
professional career
invited a traditionalist muslim
of and there are many of them there are
many of us to come and discuss with him
the matters that he's discussing
why only the unsympathetic to muslims
why
even though they come with the most
ridiculous anecdotal evidence
to make generalizable case or
generalizable
on uh entirety of a population which is
the muslim population in the west
why so this is something that she
you should be really thinking about for
instance my husband saying
the argument will no it won't go
anywhere because you will not be
able to get the statistics once again
she says i don't have the data
and he once again is the softball
approach
not a pushing not attacking
because she's not from the left because
she's not a white
second wave feminist woman from the left
that's why he's dealing with her in that
way
and because she has this bias against
islam and she echoes a lot of
their sentiments again the right wing
let's be
honest alt right-wing sentiments that's
why he's being taken easy with her
even though she is telling him i don't
have any data
he should have said if you don't have
any data you don't have any case
that's what you should have said full
stop her books are littered
with anecdotal information which even
that
is questionable and you can see in the
other refutation i've done on her
even that is questionable and has been
fact checked and she has been proven to
be
a malignant liar on all of these issues
victims and perpetrators of violent
crimes about 50 percent of them are
alcohol intoxicated it's a massive
contributor to
to violence of all types domestic
violence every type of violence
at minute 28 he starts talking about
other factors one of which is alcohol
something which is a prohibition in
islam
and she can see the discomfort in the
face of iron hersey because now it's
moving away from
anti-islamic attack to almost seemingly
a pseudo pro-islamic stance because
islam is the only
major world religion which bans alcohol
and he talks about alcohol being
in his his words 50 or more
the reason why a lot of these
attacks happen against women she tries
to sidestep that and move it back to an
anti-islamic case
but she is losing sophistication she
unnuances the discussion
and she's just trying to squeeze in she
is desperately trying to squeeze
in an anti-islamic narrative at
every single turn
but jordan peterson does not care
because jordan peterson is happy to
acquiesce with that
and jordan peterson is happy to have
these unsympathetic muslim
anti-muslim people on his show like uh
gad zad
or whatever his name is and her uh
hersey ali and
sam harris you all quite frankly you
have one thing in common which is
you echo the same nonsense when it comes
to islam and you are afraid
you are afraid to come out of your echo
chambers you are afraid
this is probably the most shocking bit
of the entire interview
she talks candidly
and audaciously about imposing
western values on immigrant populations
at any time
there was a proposition to yes impose
the values of liberal societies on the
incoming minorities there would be an
opposition to that this still
is an opposition to that now imagine me
saying the same
thing about islam let's impose
islam upon if i was speaking in a
context where islam was a
majority or the dominant ethic and we're
talking about immigrants to muslim lands
i say exactly the same thing
i'll be labeled a fascist an
authoritarian
impose the islamic values on oncoming
non-muslim populations imagine i said
that in in relation to
non-muslim immigrants in the muslim land
everyone would say this is
uh brutal authoritarianism and fascism
but the man who seems to be or
he's putting himself out to be
a figure an emblem for free speech and
expression and liberalism in the west
jordan peterson instead of having the
courage
to challenge iron hersey ali
on this very statement he
acquiesces and moves on and in fact
seems to even agree with the sentiment
which which baffles me to the point of
asking this question
to what extent can liberalism
ostensibly an ideology
of tolerance tolerate anything other
than itself
and you have jordan peterson who is
meant to be the bastion of sp
free speech and freedom of expression
who is acquiescing to this once again
because of his cognitive
bias towards islam and muslim instead of
challenging her on this
in fact jordan peterson
speaks of immigration
in this kind of language he says the
simplest explanation could well be that
canada's geographical
position has protected it against
many of the events or shielded us
against many of the events that have
made immigration such a contentious
issue
as if immigrants are some kind of threat
some extraneous threat that require
shielding from
in that they're coming with these new
ideas and cultures
that are going to undermine your
cultures
you're scared you're scared of anyone
challenging the dominant ethic
you need to be shielded from it that is
what i see
from your from the parlance from the
language that you are using
i think we and and how would you address
when you're criticized for being
a neo-colonist let's say peterson seems
to actually even agree with this
imposition narrative
by playing devil's advocate and
saying well some may accuse us of being
neo-colonists
peterson is not only acquiescing with
hercy but he seems to agree with her on
this narrative
and it's only at minute 53
second 45 where he has the conversation
that he needs to have or he asked the
question which he needs to have
we should should we assume the primacy
of values
no we shouldn't assume the primacy of
values let's take a look at what he has
to say
don't do you think that there is a
danger in
in the western assertion of primacy of
value for example and
is is that such a danger that it
mitigates against
any attempts to assimilate immigrants
for example
how can you assume the primacy of values
without
having an epistemological basis for
doing so
without arguing it for from it from
first principles
so what you're saying effectively is
this immigrants have to come in
we should assume the primacy of our
values over theirs and we should impose
it on them
without even trying to argue with them
in rational ways
for them to believe in what we believe
this to me
is the biggest indication of a failure
of values
what kind of values are these this is
exactly the
this is exactly the colonial approach
and yes you will be criticized of that
and you know why
and then she starts talking about the
prevalence of sexually transmitted
disease at minute 56
unwanted diseases unwanted babies rapes
and sexual violence
all of that in western societies seem to
be really
different as if there's kind of this
western
kind of exclusivity no there's no such
thing and she hasn't offered us any data
and what sexually transmitted diseases
she's talking about and comparative to
what
so once again she's just she does not
have any facts in front of her she's
just
ready to spill over her she's ready to
speak about her anecdotes but she
doesn't really have any facts to talk
about
so you contrast
an islamic attitude towards women with a
western attitude towards women
now what she doesn't want to get into is
a theological discussion because she has
no knowledge on this topic
so when it comes to comparison now it's
going to be quite complicated because
which kind of islam are we talking about
which kind of judo christianity we're
talking about
is judaism similar or i mean judaism has
a has a system of
ethics or a law system which is similar
to sharia and islam
christianity doesn't have that there are
nuances that need to be discussed and
fleshed out
nuances that actually ayan hershey ali
will not have no business
and has no expertise in being able to
answer this question so she diverts this
question
she's good for nothing really quite
frankly in this conversation she diverts
this question and starts talking about
other things
they they like the gadgets and the
nuclear weapons
and that sort of modern stuff that
makes them feel dominant it's just the
kind of way she speaks
she says that the only uh the muslims as
if we're one monolith
there's not x amount of countries that
are muslim countries that one quarter of
the world's population or whatever it
may be according to pew
we're one monolith one uh block
and she says yeah these muslims are only
they only like uh
techno advancements and so on when it
relates to nuclear weapons and
other gadgets like that nuclear weapons
so she's trying to kind of create
associative
uh links between muslims and nuclear
weapons
well the only ones who have detonated
nuclear weapons are the united states of
america they have the most nuclear
weapons what are you talking about
there's only one muslim country with
nuclear weapons
which is pakistan so what on earth are
you talking about we only like nuclear
weapons it seems like you're
you're projecting your own insecurities
your own western insecurities onto us
what are you talking about bring some
facts or be quiet and go home
with all due respect you have nothing to
add you have nothing to add
that is one side of the story but
there's also another side of the story
there's two sides of the story when you
when jordan peterson talks about slavery
and segregation racism in the west she
goes there's two sides of the story you
know this
but she doesn't offer the same
charitable interpretations of two sides
of the story
when she talk about the muslim world so
why is there only two sides of the story
with the west and there's no two sides
of the story anywhere else
see this should show any sincere person
quite frankly any sincere person who's
looking for the truth that these people
are just
quite frankly stuck in their echo
chamber they make it seem like they're
academics and they open mind and they
love free speech
but honestly they don't because they
don't platform people that have
uh diametrically opposed on some issues
opinions to them they don't give people
who support
what they're opposed to in equal footing
and they don't give
us they will they will not and they will
not give us an opportunity to discuss
these
matters with them and quite frankly
listen before i would have been quite
happy to go on jordan peterson's
program and so on but now that i've seen
that he's talking about imposing values
on us
and we're talking about like cattle
whereas animals that need to have
values imposed upon us and so on there
are parents
and we are the children the muslim
children who need to be taught parental
agent
we need to be infantilized
by the western white man and his project
yes we the muslims need to come in and
be infantilized by them
to be honest unless jordan peterson or
anyone like him
wants to give us equal footing and see
us as equal people
not some infants that he can impose his
values on and he's going to speak us
with snobbery and arrogance he's going
to arrogate his
views upon us we don't even have a
conversation with them unless
they can guarantee that look we see you
as equals in this conversation and so on
we're not begging you to go on your
platform quite frankly we're not
begging this some people are gonna say
oh you did this to try and make a noise
so you can go on his platform no
to be honest i don't care i've got my
own platform i've got my own platform
i'm saying what i need to say if he
wants to speak to me he can with all due
respect
there are things that i know he doesn't
know there are things i'm trained on
that he's not trained on
and yes we can help him out in his
ignorance with islam
and that's how we're putting it but i'm
not going to come and beg him or
please come on my platform you know what
i offer it to you but if you want to
infantilize the muslim community and
pose values on them
my friend we don't need you with all
jewish we don't need you or hershey ali
who's an ignoramus who has no
business talk about islam or muslims and
we don't need any of you
in this dark web fraternity that you
have
of anti-muslim apologists who cannot
summon the courage and bravery to speak
to somebody on the other side
but already this is on the public record
and my guess is gonna get
hundreds of thousands of views and even
if it gets a hundred thousand views
it'll be enough
it'll be enough to counter the damage
that you've done and no longer
are we gonna just sit there on the
sidelines waiting for you and your
friends
yeah to talk about us as if you know who
we are and what we believe in
you don't so to be honest after i've
seen this interview
i mean before we were kind of not sure
where you stand jordan peterson
we're not sure where you stand whether
you were sincerely a person who was
looking for truth
and didn't care where it came from to a
person who
just has quite frankly people that are
anti-islamic apologists
and academics who are unsympathetic to
islam
like sam harris like godzad like
ayan hersey ali and like majid nawaz who
still calls himself a muslim but the
traditious muslim community do not
accept him you only have those people on
and you only speak to those people by
islam
so and not only that you acquiesce to
their nonsense
where we know you have the tools in your
arsenal to be able to
unpack what they believe in so here's
what i say to you jordan peterson
if you want to engage with someone who
does not agree with your paradigm and
world view
we're here we're here we can have those
discussions don't be
afraid don't be scared we're here we can
have those discussions
but what we won't accept quite frankly
is an infantilizing and arrogating
and self-congratulating narcissistic
type of
colonial yes neo-colonial attitude where
you're saying we're going to impose our
views on these
immigrants coming in and we believe in
primacy of values
or we're questioning whether we believe
in primacy or values or not
and we're going to impose those views
and yes that's something where
that is the the plan even though we
don't have data as we've seen
with diane hersey ali we don't have data
to support that actually
the allegations that are being made and
that's what they are
their sociological allegations about the
muslim community right
are in any way linked to islam as a
religion
or the muslim community as a people
so if you want to have a conversation
which is fruitful
with people within the muslim community
we are here at your service
but if you continue trying to evade
those conversations with all due respect
it is a kind of academic cowardice and
you can continue
doing these sly things and saying i'm
ignorant about islam but bring on all
the anti-islamic
apologists and people that are
anti-islamic to your show
we're not fools we know what's going on
and
the offer is there the offer is there
all you have to do is send me an email
with your name on the title and i'll
respond to it